hallo ihr sitzt bereits im titel
eingeblendet seiner lieben zuschauer ich
habe für jule klamotten bei oasis
bestellt ja ich habe schon mal ein video
auf einem kanal hochgeladen in dem jule
für mich kleidung bei erstes bestellt
hat dieses tief nicht so es deswegen
habe ich mich jetzt mal die aufgabe
gesetzt für jule kleider sorry ich habe
für juli 14 sachen bases bestellt und
die packen wird aus
das hier ist das erste produkt das ich
will dich bestellt haben und zwar ist
das ein zweiter das ist ein raues wetter
da steht westcoast auf die person
telefoniert
[Musik]
also ich glaube ich selbst wird für den
nicht bestellt aber wenn ihnen jemand
geben würde würde ich ihn anziehen so
zum schilde dass sonova sei so ein
bisschen zum chillen und wenn du dann
unterhalt sowie jeans kombiniert
eigentlich vier punkte gibt es zudem auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10
ich meine es ist den cool hannover aber
es wird nicht so richtig was ich mir
jetzt unbedingt bestellen würde
da wohl okay das war allerdings erst
produkt nummer 1 von 14 m als nächstes
habe ich für dich dass hier bestellt ich
glaube dass bei diesen links was als
essen
das ist ein body ids vorne silber
kreuzen dann ist ja so oft schulter so
eine entscheidung müssen wir da unten so
dass jetzt nicht unbedingt eine farbe
die ich so normalerweise anziehen würde
welche so lassen sich also platz wenn
generell ist er bestimmt cool wie viele
punkte 7
besser als der suizid denen man lieber
nicht vor der kamera an weil hier ist
schon habt halt und ich glaube das würde
das hier nicht noch besser dazu
beitragen das nächste produkt er sich
die bestellt habe ist lanciert
dies von der marke sunglasses ukip das
ist die marke hier ist übrigens nichts
gesponsert in dem video also weder races
hat wegen den rabatt gegeben oder
irgendwas kostenlos gegeben noch
bekommen wir irgendwelche produkte hier
umsonst allerdings geht es jetzt erst
mal um die sonnenbrille das ist eine
sonnenbrille da weiß ich du hast sondern
in etwa ähnliche firmen soll hier aber
manchmal ein bisschen peinlich ist und
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich bestellt
die diese ein bisschen mehr
das war nochmal auf
ich finde die nicht so gut wie viele
punkte wirst du der sonnenbrille auf das
grab von 1 bis 10 geben es ist jetzt an
brille generell sind das lieben gehen
möchte eigentlich ganz gut dabei mir
wirklich die runde zwei geben ich würde
bei dir mit 10 geben und das nächste
produkt das ich die bestellt habe ist
das hier das ist nett printnet front-
heck- band no shit ist da nicht so
schlecht dass auf dem foto
also das hier ist dieses front- heck-
band superstar was auch sonst was sonst
ich meine was auch sonst ist das macht
man sich dann glaube ich nicht richtig
im kopf
es gab zwei größeres gab es und ich
finde ich es genommen wenn paar sekunden
später die sonne oberbayern dennoch jule
wie viele punkte würdest du diesen zebra
have band geben 3 noch einmal sehen wie
jude damit außer das nächste produkt das
sich die hier bestellt habe ist eine
hose es ist eine kurze dass das tier das
die kurze hose die ich gestellt haben
also das ist diese jeans shorts wie ich
mir bestellt habe ich dachte damals
keine schwarzen doch anders die schule
hat nun die schwarze denn im shorttrack
zogen
so sieht sie aus wie viel punkte kriegt
sie 66 und halb sechs kanal von 10 für
die schwarze schon das nächste dass sich
die gestellt habe ist eine jacke und
zwar hoch aber das würden in freundin
grinsen oder er soll so sieht das foto
auf der us-webseite aus die krasse
ausnahme stinken bis die man ließ die
scheiße das hätte ich mal hin
also ich finde die nicht schlecht wie
viel punkte punkte willst du dir geben
6 wie sollen fesche mädel das nächste
produkt das sich die bestellt habe ist
das hier
8 das war eine bomberjacke glaube ich
dafür jetzt erst mal das foto wie sie
bei es aussieht und weißes kurzes
t-shirt und hundert lieder drüber und
dann im sommer mit nach einem schwarzen
rose das finde ich ehrlich wie viele
punkte geblieben dass jetzt das produkt
das sich außerdem noch weißes bestellt
habe das ist ein oberstes boxee kropp
sweatshirt in laim
ein over size sweatshirt was aber
gedroppt ist also hier über könntest du
dann theoretisch so eine schwarze jacke
anziehen oder so im sommer ist nicht so
schnell ist halt auch was heißt aber
sieht auch so aus als wäre es auch was
heißt also ich find es sieht gar nicht
mal so schlecht sind jetzt herein gucke
bis zum ersten mal etwas anderes tricks
als schwarz wie viele punkte willst du
denn diesem cops yellow lounge wetter
geben 77
als nächstes habe ich dir dann hier eine
hose bestellt das ist ein kleid
ist auf jeden fall ein kleid was ich
denke was so richtig der julis teil ist
ja so denn nicht zensierte bereich ist
ganz gut so wie es ist bei mir ja es ist
viel zu engen glaub ich erlöst hat sich
gedanken gemacht wie viele punkte wirst
du an diesem kleid geben ich glaube
sogar 9 also ich bestelle mir das auf
jeden fall nochmal namen größer aber
ganz kurz wenn du es dir doch noch mal
bestellt dann müsste doch eigentlich den
ich werde die medizin noch offen halten
vielleicht kommt ja noch das safe das
nächste produkt ist nächste produkt es
nämlich noch mal eine sonnenbrille die
saison tatsächlich nur zwei euro
gekostet und die sieht so aus als es ist
nicht so beschissen aus
die sache ist halt bei dem erstes foto
seht ihr gerade eingeblendet sah es
finde ich gar nicht mal so scheiße aus
aber wie viele punkte würdest du dieser
sonnenbrille geben auf einer skala von 1
bis 10 6 also ich finde es eigentlich
ganz cool alter dachte gibt es wenn sie
einem stehst du clos das nächste produkt
das ich hier für dich bestellt habe bei
erstes wort und gibt es tatsächlich ein
typisches produkt ist es einfach ein
schwarzer sweater ich weiß dass das was
die meisten tricks meine schwarzen
moody's sind
es ist ein zweiter bei der sowieso ein
schwarzes asic über teile wie viele
punkte würdest du diesen schwarzen basic
obertal geben 77
damit kann man eigentlich seid ja okay
das hat ein schwarzes oberteil das
nächste dass ich hier für dich bestellt
habe ist ein hut im sommer das wird halt
perfekten diesen blau weißen kleid
passen
ich bin sauer
es geht hier ja auch nicht meine liebe
deswegen selbst über mal deinen lieben
cowboyhut hier sind halt aus der sonne
ab morgen kommen wie viele punkte wird
zudem gut auf einer skala von 1 bis 10
geben
6 ok danke das vorletzte produkt was ich
für dich bestellt habe ist das hier
ich wollte sich auch wenn es nicht auf
die männer bottrop browser in einem
check das ist eine rose die liegt jetzt
nicht direkt an der haut an sondern ist
halt so locker für den sommer und du
kannst richtung gebohrt und marketing
geburt am markt waren dunkelrot nie also
magst du nicht mein her nicht zeigen wie
viele punkte willst du diese unfassbare
hose geben 3 das letzte produkt was wir
hier am start haben sind schuhe von aces
natürlich und zweimal habe ich auch hier
natürlich der an den sommer gedacht die
bevorstehende jahreszeit ausweises
solche schuhe
das ist schult die fan tatsächlich unter
diesem kleid oder unter irgendwas
anderem waren die auf jeden fall mit
runter verlinkt und die meinten so etwas
portugiesen locator allgemeinwohl schuhe
stehen ja eigentlich ganz gut wenn du
also gross wechselte also wie bereits
gesagt die schuhe wurden in verbindung
mit diesem kleid irgendwie an dieser
hose gegen die angebotenen deswegen wie
viele punkte würdest du so nun den
schulen geben
5 das spaß tatsächlich dann auch wenn
euch dieses video hier gefallen hat er
das gerne einen daumen hoch da und
schreibt uns gerne in die kommentare
wer sich besser geschlagen hat also hat
juli für mich damals bessere sachen
gekauft oder ich jetzt für juli
[Musik]